good morning
millennials welcome back to the morning
toast and have
a happy friday friday
gotta get down on friday that's right
the rumors are true you may have heard
it but we're here to confirm
it's [ __ ] friday so acknowledge the
space that you're in appreciate the
space that you're in
feel hopeful feel excited feel
friday it's a beautiful beautiful space
you guys we did it we
one out of seven days feel this way
congratulations
and um thank you congratulations to you
as well i'm just
feeling so so excited i knew we could do
it i really did because we've done it
before
we've done it i would say for me 52
times 28
a little quick math that's how many
times i've done it how many times is
that i don't know
okay um ben is actually really good at
doing like multiplication like he could
tell you like
75 times 32 and he'll explain how he
does it and it makes no [ __ ] sense
okay
52 times 28 but then also um i'm gonna
add like
plus 31 because a half a year eight
years
i have enjoyed 1487 fridays
in my life well congratulations on
getting to
and your 1487 thank you so much if this
one feels different than the other 100
let's acknowledge the space that we're
in it's friday we're so far away from
monday but also we're like kind of close
um we're just feeling good it's a
holiday weekend
we must acknowledge the space that we're
in juneteenth is an official
federal holiday yes it is congress
passed like 400 to like 10.
yes very exciting happy juneteenth
tomorrow is juneteenth yeah so
celebrate educate it's a great holiday
and we're excited to celebrate
we are and we're just excited to
acknowledge the space that we're in yeah
constantly
100 and we have a lot to get into today
i'm really looking forward
to today's show because of what
transpired last night on the e-network
at 8pm
eastern time well for me it transpired
at 9am this morning because i don't know
if
others were affected and i was following
closely to the situation on twitter
monitoring the situation
spectrum was having outages all over the
country my neighborhood was hit
i know places in california where hey
it's like [ __ ] spectrum
because not only spectrum my wi-fi
provider so i couldn't work on my
computer i couldn't watch anything on
apple tv or stream
they're also my cable provider so i
couldn't watch cable and i have to say
yesterday was
the longest day of my life and by the
time i went out to dinner i had a couple
drinks and i was like
by the time i get home like it'll be
fixed nope sat in the pitch black by
myself ben was gone
never been so bored in my whole life
honestly spectrum [ __ ] you maybe if you
had a business that you were passionate
about you would know what it's like
but you don't because you let a whole
[ __ ] nationwide outage happen
for literally 16 hours yesterday
nationwide i don't know i was in
my building's gym and their spectrum and
the tvs were on and my wi-fi was
possible i was monitoring the situation
people in california were struck
they obviously had some sort of internal
problem and it's not my business to
figure it out but like the fact that it
took them so goddamn long to get it back
on track like disgusts me
yeah oh my god so boring and i never
realized like
wi-fi is literally everything so i was
like okay alexa like play some music
no alexa was out for the couch she told
me to go [ __ ] myself literally
but you didn't turn to your kindle in
your time of need no and it was right
next to me and i was thinking like i
could read but if you're not in the mood
to read like it's just not gonna make
you in the mood no
sometimes you have to power through and
then all of a sudden and then you're in
it sometimes you're not just like
itching to read i do that all the time
where i'm like
i don't really want to read but i should
start a book and then i'll i'll be
reading
yeah like i guess i just like couldn't
motivate myself and i honestly just
got really creative with things to pass
my time i went live on instagram
um and i read the first 50 pages of my
book and people really seemed to like it
i read it out loud
i i stumbled into the chat oh did you
and you know what i wanted to check
because i wanted to see like if i sold
any books because so many people were
like coming in who don't follow me
you didn't have wi-fi so you really
couldn't do anything and you were so
bored but you were able to go live on
instagram
yeah 5g right so why couldn't you do
anything else on your phone
i could like i was watching tick tocks
but like do you know how boring that
gets after
four hours i just wanna make it clear
like you made it seem like you were
sitting in the dark with a candle
yesterday i was last night last night i
was but no i was getting creative during
the day i went live on instagram
and my book because like my book came
out so long ago on the amazon like
millions of books list it was at 35
000. then after my my slam poetry he
said fourteen thousand wow
so i think i sold some books yesterday
available at amazon.com girlsnowjob.com
love it um so i did that and then i
don't know if you i know you don't watch
my stories with sound because you hate
me i do not because i've made it clear
that i don't and you refuse to amend
also you could do this new thing that
people are doing where their stories get
like closed captioning
that's what you should do i haven't
gotten that feature yet
no it's something it's an external they
added it
to now instagram okay oh my god i just
choked
i'm so sorry i hate that sound that's
what you need no i know but also
like what i was doing yesterday on my
story it's like you really needed to
listen to what were you doing i wrote an
original song did you not see it i heard
about the song i think i caught the tail
end of it
honestly i was really impressed with
myself because i've always loved to sing
and i've always played guitar
but i never thought i could actually
write a song and it took me five minutes
and obviously it wasn't good but i
actually think i might be able to write
a song now
what was your song about what was what
was have you feeling inspired
i'm living living living living in
colonial times
say her in the dark with a candle i'm
feeling feeling feeling like spectrum's
committing a crime
if i ever make it out of here i will
feel so
alive it was good see you don't even
[ __ ] listen
this is really good the br the verses
weren't that good but as i started to
like do it more i started to get good
and then i ended up with like a pretty
bomb chorus
wow what was it called i didn't get
there colonial times
yeah probably damn your spectrum's
committing a crime
wow okay so look you had your creative
juices flowing not all was bad
i was left to my own devices and forced
you to sell some books to write a song
yeah to call your family because you
were hitting all of us out
trying to be entertained and like nobody
else was getting olivia
i think has verizon wi-fi like do you
have spectrum wi-fi
i have no idea yeah so like no one was
having my problem do you think i have
spectrum
oh nice for you i'm gonna call though
like and be
a karen because like i don't really feel
like i should have paid full price for
cable and wi-fi when i didn't have cable
and wi-fi for a whole day
yeah like i'm just gonna be that girl
not even so much
for the money because it'll be literally
ten dollars for the principal like
i want you to feel as tortured as i felt
yeah like you need to go in and find out
what 24 hours worth of cable and wi-fi
costs right that for me like what's my
bill divided by 30
minus that amount yeah i
i do i i'm gonna do that like i'm just i
was so annoyed i almost called last
night but i like had had a drink and i
was like maybe it's not for the best
that's good yeah that's good so that's
what i did what'd you do
i had a very busy day i finished lala's
book which was really good
yeah it was a really fun read i haven't
read a light book in
so long so it was like a really easy
quick read and it was just nice to just
breeze through a book and not have to
like
you know spend time seriously and hours
on it so that was really fun called give
them lala by lala kent
and did you in fact give them allah i
didn't give them all i don't think i
i've given lala since but i i
i now understand what giving allah
entails your man made out with my friend
no but she really explains well like how
lala and lauren like the differences
between there were a few passages i
actually felt like you would really
relate to
i bookmarked them i'll i'll i'll send
you a picture yeah
um so that was really fun i hung out
with brew he was like just
amazing and so sweet and i hit up the
gym
i got a wax it was it was a very
productive day it was
i hit the town last night not so hard
you and
snatcher went to american bar without
american camper can you believe well so
i told you that i was pretty sure like
margaret just texted me like want to go
to dinner and like when a gen z or asks
you out to dinner like you don't ask
questions like you just oblige
but a blind chip a black j it's a hard g
yeah okay i made it like fresh so
she asked me to go to dinner and i was
like oh my god of course
and then she was like i want to go to
american bar but there's no reservations
and of course like you know her cool
older sister like i was able to secure
the reservation
and then i was just feeling insecure
like did she only ask me out to dinner
because she knew i could get the
reservation um
and i was like feeling really insecure
and then when we got to dinner i was
like
it's okay like did you just use me like
for my clout you know and she was like
no
i was trying to be nice because i know
ben's out of town so it's actually
really thoughtful of her like
i the she was being thoughtful counselor
which is a counselor we really rarely
say
she was definitely thinking of everyone
not you
not me but you guys went to lunch
together literally on my block
without telling me two weeks ago and if
i hadn't facetimed you i never would
have found out so it hurts doesn't it
it does hurt it really really does and
the thing and the thing is it's like
centers coming between us
oh my god it's a satcheler
she is but you know what we always say
like because it's so difficult because
like if two of us hang out
that should be allowed like yeah but but
if three of us hang out and we don't
invite the fourth like that's [ __ ] up
that's
criminal but like i still was like
really hurt like when you guys went to
lunch
and i wouldn't i would be lying if i
said that like i wasn't getting back at
you last night like
because counselor is always coming
between us like you should have invited
me
you know what you were on my blog it
wasn't it wasn't
premeditated which yours last night was
like there was texting there was
probably open table or you know however
rezzy and for us like we were running an
errand she was
actually returning your birthday present
that you got her right so she was like
she wasn't layered she wasn't gonna
invite you to return your gift no but i
would have accepted a lunch invitation
but no we were just gonna do the gift
return but
there was a 40 minute wait to get into
the store so we just went across the
street and had lunch for the 40 minutes
it wasn't premeditated whereas yours was
hurtful nonetheless and so i'm sorry
that i took it out on you
but also your grandma and like dinner
was kind of late and you know what's so
sad it's like we could band together
and we go to dinner and we'll show that
she doesn't care she wouldn't even
care um yeah so i did have a nice time
though
i'm glad i'm happy for you you're always
looking for a nice time i am and you
know who i met
50 cent amazing i know it was crazy what
a nice guy
give me a hug i went in for a handshake
like a freight how did you go up to him
he was with someone i knew okay and my
friend amanda and
i went over to say hi to her and i do
know that she like works with him i'm
like is happy
time and he would like he didn't like he
stopped with her to like say hi and give
me and margo both hugs he was like so
nice
wow yeah that's pretty cool no i know
like i think i might be like one of the
most famous people i've ever met 100
and he couldn't have been lovelier
[Laughter]
good one thanks um always um
there's always influencers and cool
people bopping around yeah and i was in
like a cool part of town you know like
where the kids go
yeah yeah but usually it's like
influencers that are there i wouldn't
expect like 50 cents like that's
another level of star power that's
really exciting so when i went to dinner
i took an uber and i was wearing these
like little jeffrey campbell like little
sandals
and i stepped out of the uber and i
rolled my ankles
so hard and you know when you like lose
your balance you let out like a hoo
well at least i do and i uh in the
middle of the street
and this girl was staring at me the
whole time and like i know like i just i
knew she was a toaster and she was like
gonna come say hi but then when she saw
me embarrass myself she didn't
and now she's no longer a toaster no and
i just wanted to thank that girl because
like if you would come up to me like i
would have been so embarrassed like for
my own like sanity and so i know like
like i just wanted to say like it was a
choice that you made to ignore me after
that fall and i really really appreciate
it because like
my ego could not have been more bruised
and it just would have made matters
worse
okay that's really sweet yeah okay well
maybe she wasn't a chester and like i
invented this whole thing in my mind
100 or like she didn't do it to spare
you she was just like oh that's the girl
who i thought was cool
no no she was like walking i find a new
podcast jackie she was like
walking my way and then when i fell she
just like
veered oh you know what she swerved on
me i can relate to her because sometimes
the best thing you can do when you see
someone embarrass themself
is pretend like you didn't see it for
their sake and for your own like how do
you
navigate that i don't know yeah a
hundred percent
yeah um yeah it was rough we have a
great show for you guys today
we've got the fast five stories some
updated stories from earlier in the week
and then we're gonna talk about the
keeping up with the kardashians recap
that i was able to watch this morning
that's where the tangent started andy
cohen
the kardashians live on e part two is on
sunday of this week it's not next
thursday
great it's the sooner the better i agree
i need more of it
it was the most amazing thing not one
minute was wasted every question was on
point like every answer they were really
trying to be
as candid as possible while also having
each other's backs and it was just like
a beautiful thing to see
completely agree so let's just breeze
through the past five so we can talk
about what we really want to talk about
hundred percent without further ado
where are you right here sleeping so
cute it is time for the pastime stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
theo's gonna have such a great weekend
in the country we're heading to uncle
brian's house and he's just so excited
to see his cousins and his friends
um today's episode is brought to you by
patreon.com morning toast
what is patreon it is our subscription
service so the morning toast it's five
days a week sometimes four when we're
feeling lazy
um and it's totally free we'll never
charge you for it we'll see um but we
have a subscription service for 7.99 a
month if you're looking for more
episodes head over to patreon.com
your morning toast you'll get five extra
episodes every month sometimes it's
podcasts sometimes it's vlogs it's
always a little bit more behind the
scenes we get the sisters involved
olivia margot
home tours vlogs jackie dress me tons of
new content five episodes a month and if
you become a member now
not only do you get access to all of our
old episodes so it's like over 200
you also get access to our facebook
group the toast after dark so check that
out patreon.com slash morning toast
great way to get some new content and
support your favorite podcast
yes we love the patreon check it out
patreon.com super personal and
funny and interesting wait um what was
that link again patreon.com thank you so
much
and like if you sign up today you have
content for years
weeks like seriously okay first story a
little update from
news of the week erica jane's attorneys
backtrack
after withdrawing representation so they
are
two days after erica jane's legal team
filed documents to cut ties with the
reality star it seems as though they've
had a change of heart yes
the legalities are quite emotional it
seems according to documents filed on
june 17th and obtained by e news erica's
attorneys have formally
withdrawn their motion to withdraw as
counsel for the bravo star amid her
legal proceedings involving estranged
husband tom gerardi
however no further statement has been
made on the legal reconciliation
what is going on this is so shady like i
actually like i have no theories here
i'm so confused i have no theory i'm so
confused and i feel like
my only theory would be that they're
intentionally trying to confuse us so
that we lose interest
and that like this doesn't become as big
of a deal as
it will become i mean that's definitely
a thing like there's so many stories
going on right now where there's so much
back and forth and i think we're going
to talk about it like michael costello
chrissy teigen like
eventually there's so much back and
forth i don't even care anymore um i'm
not even close to getting there with
erica jane because i have
so many questions no no i have so many
questions and thank you to the housewife
for and the hustler for keeping me
abreast
and wanting me keeping me wanting to
stay abreast
also another erica jane update is that
she's moved into a new house
it's a 7 500 a month rental near beverly
hills but outside beverly hills
um and i was watching i think it was a
page six tick tock and like they were
just being shady like showing the houses
from like the worst [ __ ] angles you
know like
and of course it needs work and erica
jane will you know free it up but it was
like rental photos like from zillow
and it was just like a little sad
interesting so she's renting she didn't
buy
yeah interesting yeah so i have no idea
why they left
and i feel like it's so uncommon i feel
like it's very out of the ordinary for
like a legal team to fire you and even
more out of the ordinary for them to
rehire you i mean i'm not a lawyer
but it's just not something we're
familiar with yeah this is just very
like shady and weird and i
have even more questions than possible
earlier in the week i had questions and
now i'm left with even more
yeah me too so if anybody has a theory
let us know comment on today's you know
instagram post on the morning toast
or on youtube or on youtube i'm i'm
genuinely like searching for theories
iso theories because i have no idea what
this could possibly
be hinting towards or telling us i don't
know
ow i just got to switch i'm like really
confused
yeah i'm malfunctioning we're taking
theories and then maybe we'll read some
of them next week
okay next up chrissy teigen's team
claims michael costello posted fake
screenshot of alleged bullying
christy tweeken's team is addressing the
bullying accusations recently made by
fashion designer michael costello
against the star
in an article published by business
insider on thursday a team
representative for tegan claimed the
purported instagram direct messages
from chrissy are fake the no the outlet
noted the screenshot showed several
temporal inconsistencies that may
suggest they had been altered in some
way
may examples include a missing verified
check mark next to tegan's name
which would suggest the screenshots were
taken in 2014 before instagram's
verification program had launched
in the same screen grab featuring purple
and blue messages
a design implemented by the social media
platform in 2020
yeah so honestly i feel like i've really
been on michael costello's side this
whole time but like
those are very valid um discrepancies
like
yeah if her check mark wasn't there that
means that the screenshot had to be
taken in 2014. but the fact that the
messages are purple that's a new thing
yeah things didn't look like that in
2014 right they were like gray and blue
so
and if you took the screenshot recently
when there would be a check there would
be a check mark so honestly like
at first i was just like i brushed off
like of course she's gonna say they're
not real but after i read the
the discrepancies like it's kind of
valid yeah i'm looking forward to
hearing from michael costello because um
as we've learned this week it seems like
he has a lot of receipts and he's stuck
let me just check see if he even
responded
because honestly this could be solved
with one
screen recording like that's it no if
not if chrissy on sent
the messages well that would be crazy oh
michael costello has nothing let's see
two days ago was his last post just like
thanking everyone saying he was like
going to hop off
interesting um i don't know now i'm i'm
truly i'm
it's a dangerous choice it's the game of
ping pong yeah and i'm just
but i am starting to lose interest yeah
as one does
yeah at first when he like blew up her
spot i was like oh my god this is so
like juicy and crazy
yeah and now i'm just like i with the
iliana lewis of it all and the fakes
yeah i'm waiting for one more response
for michael before i check out yeah i
feel
like i i feel like i took michael's
aside initially
one because like the accusations were so
heinous and two because it's clear i
feel like he i mean i don't know him but
just like from following him on social
media he's very fresh
like in a fragile mental state um
so i just kind of like feel for him and
felt for him but now i'm just confused
yeah and otherwise how do you explain
his
career stagnant career yeah well maybe
then just like
if if that if this isn't like maybe he
just didn't cut it you know like
but we all like know what his clothes
look like and the dress
and he does like there is a weird talent
is there there's a weird arc of his
career project runway so big dress
beyonce
has a line of revolve like how does it
make any sense yeah so
that's why i'm gonna wait this one out
yeah
but he's been responding to everything
like almost immediately and now it's
like been a full
like 14 hours that's long for michael
because it is
maybe he's sleeping maybe are you ready
for our next story it's an update from a
story i shared a while ago
and it's not a good update oh no cody
simpson's olympic
dream ends in a brutal fashion no
cody simpson's road to the tokyo
olympics has reached a dead end the 24
year old australian singer
turned olympic hopeful failed to qualify
for the postponed 2020 games on thursday
night
at the australian olympic trials in
adelaide
simpson needed to record a time less
than 51.7 seconds to punch a ticket
to tokyo he fell short and touched the
wall at 52.94 seconds and what did he
need to get 51.7
he was at 52.94 well one second off yes
he placed
last in the final behind aussie swimmer
matthew temple
wow honestly i'm so glad you updated me
i totally forgot that we had reported
that cody simpson like was
trying to go to the olympics and he
didn't make it and that's very sad but
you did just remind me that the olympics
are
so close and i just want to let you know
like for the two week period that the
olympics are on like i will exclusively
be wearing red white and blue
i will be glued to my tv i'm obsessed
with the olympics obsessed with the
summer olympics
especially summer and
i think that's where my thought ended
but i'm so excited i'm so excited now
i'm just curious like
do you think all the banners and
everything and all the fanfare are going
to say 2020
or 2021 because like these are the 2020
olympics well the next summer olympics
be 24 or 25 24
i'm so glad we're getting back on track
yeah we're getting back on track i agree
i'm so excited about this and it's like
look how excited we got about
jake paul fighting floyd mayweather
because we wanted to be a part of
something and now we're going to be a
part of like the
biggest thing on earth that literally
has been going on since like
greek times and everyone just gets like
so patriotic and we all get together
not enough people are getting excited
for the olympics and i feel like there's
been a lot of
there's been a lot of controversy around
the olympics and like people saying not
to go
because like a quote and this and that
but like we need to start getting a
little more excited and we need to start
like pumping up our athletes i
completely
completely agree i've been watching like
they have some olympic trials they're so
hard to find on tv but they're going on
right now and like i want to watch
because i saw like a couple minutes of
katie ledecky like she's our girl like
she is taking us to the swimming
champions like we here support katie
ledecky like she's our number one girl
i've been trying to find like all these
trials but it's so hard to find they
don't play them on like basic cable you
have to get like espn 11. like who the
[ __ ] has that
but i'm gearing up like i need to get
some outfits i think like every single
day on the toes like i'm wearing
something even crazier like i'm so
excited because
i just feel like it's been such a hard
couple years especially in america like
of course covered but we've been so
divided and like we all just rally
together like as americans and it's just
gonna be exciting like excitement
excites me
yeah i really agree i don't know when
they kick off but
we'll be there with your official
olympic commentary and who
are like the stars you know did you see
the um american
synchronized swimming um qualifying
performance okay it was all robot themed
and it was like these
sickening six girls and they were so in
sync like truly synchronized swimming
and the whole um like dance aesthetic
was like
and it was so good like it was so good
amazing i mean gabby douglas is a star
yes is gymnastics summer summer yeah
okay
and i'm pretty sure i saw a headline
that ryan lochte is trying
to make it back okay i like loved
ryan lochte like remember when he had a
show on e yeah what was it called
loc delicious i don't know living lochte
that's what i thought
you know that's living low hand it was
like life with ryan you know someone
life of ryan no it was like it was
keeping up with the lock to easy yes yes
yes yes what the [ __ ] was it called i'm
i'm finding out now
i'm fine what would ryan lock to do
terrible
horrible name we just gave you so many
good names
so good um
yeah so like i just like was obsessed
with him but then he had like a weird
incident in brazil
yeah where like he said he was attacked
and like he wasn't yeah yeah
um okay so that was weird but i'm
willing to look past
for the sake of america yeah hopefully
he brings um
we just need to bring home some medals
like i'm so competitive with the
olympics
they start july 23rd and they go on for
like two or three weeks and i'm just
august 8th i'm going to be that's like
not long enough that's only two weeks
i'm gonna be watching on rotation like i
don't even know if i can come to the
toes because i can't take a break from
the olympics
oh yeah and tokyo is what time zone like
what time are we gonna be watching i
think that they still air things in
prime time
like right no i feel like it's live i
don't think so no it's not live
remember that guy bob osborne who had
pinkeye
yes bob
bob pink guy bob cos
bob costas yeah bob costas does he still
do the uh
i don't know i think after pink eye and
now that it's like everybody's on alert
for instance right it's like get your
infectious [ __ ] eye
out of here
like we can't afford another pandemic
bob
that was such a funny time see like
that's what i miss like we all just like
getting together and making fun of bob's
eye like
we just need to i'm just so desperate to
feel a part of something in the olympics
there's nothing bigger like literally
it's the same as like when we talk about
like mexi like it's so global
but like it's bigger it's every country
like so
it's the thing so exciting like when
does it come back to new york
or not new york obviously like america
please don't ever bring it to new york
please we can't handle it like we will
like the capacity will kill us
yeah okay let's see olympics location
location schedule
schedule yeah so it's in tokyo this year
and then it's in l.a in 2020
i'm [ __ ] going and you know what
let's do a live show from like the
swimming competition from la in 2028
okay i'll see you there
that's so exciting yeah so exciting i
love the olympics so
go america um if anyone can let me know
like where to like watch more trials and
stuff i'm just like really
um i'm hooked i'm hooked on phonics so
okay wait here's where the next olympics
are just in case anybody was curious so
oh tokyo is now being called 2021 i
guess
because it's 2021. um 2022 is beijing
for the winter
wow so there's only one year we're gonna
get two olympics wow
the next summer 2024 paris
french camper will be in attendance will
emily be in attendance
no they said good band
2026 milan italian camper will be there
for the winter olympics thickening
and then 2028 l.a okay this is a dumb
question but like
does it snow in milan well they build
all the things
that's crazy like yeah crazy
crazy um okay so like just wanted to put
that on your radar like we will be
covering the olympics so [ __ ] hard
like
i can't wait can't wait i need to start
getting some outfits but we're sorry to
cody simpson we would have loved to see
you up there shaking that thing i
actually really would rather see him up
there shaking that thing but um
i'm sure there's other like really hot
australian swimmers like we'll just have
to live
we will we will have to land that's like
actually crazy that he came within
one second of qualifying like that's
actually very impressive good you should
feel very proud of himself
yeah exactly don't be upset it's over
smile that it happened cody smile that
you almost made it yeah
next up a little podcasting news spotify
is buying pods a podcast discovery tech
startup
whose backers included katie couric and
paris hilton i never heard of it
so pods is a startup that developed an
auto-generated audio news feed for
podcasts
wait sorry say it again an audio
auto-generated audio news feed for
podcasts like an algorithm
yeah it's like technology spotify said
we believe that pods's technology will
complement and accelerate spotify's
focused efforts to drive discovery
deliver listeners the right content at
the right time and accelerate growth of
the category world r
worldwide i'm sorry like spotify is just
like absolutely slant
slaying i was gonna say slandering
slaying the podcast industry like
uh other apps should be and are quaking
and i don't really feel like apple's
doing
enough absolutely being stagnant like
they think they're at the top and that
they're gonna stay there but like
they're like not and they're not
innovating they just released this
like their whole new june podcast so all
these different things you can now do
subscription services
on apple which is cool but they do take
30 of people's revenue and i don't think
a lot of creators are willing to give up
that amount of money
and they also introduce channels so like
they think that channels are going to
compete like
i don't i looked at a podcast with a
channel and a podcast without a channel
and the two looked exactly the same so
like
i just don't really feel like they're
doing enough to compete and all these
other apps like that are falling behind
like i heart radio like everyone needs
to get their [ __ ] together
yeah everybody needs to get their [ __ ]
together spotify is quickly becoming
like the biggest conglomerate in the
podcasting space and podcasting is
getting so big
and i'm telling you in five years like
people are only gonna be listening to
podcasts
on spotify at this rate that's their
plan well other
companies you'd start stepping up and
they're laying the groundwork for that
okay i don't know why everyone is being
so
slow it's like chill about it
fair for sure yeah but so um i don't
know what this technology is but i guess
it's just gonna make it so like when you
open spotify they're going to show you
podcasts that you
would want to see maybe i kind of think
of it like i think that spotify's
algorithm for discovery is like so
amazing and
for so many years like i found so many
artists and songs that i never would
have heard thanks to spotify so maybe
the same will be true for podcasts like
they will know your taste and be able to
recommend like
what yeah recommend well shows that you
would like right like what they did for
music for so many people i agree they
they uh like using artists and so maybe
like for emerging podcasts like i think
it
makes a lot of sense to me yeah me too
how much did they buy for did they say
undisclosed
damn happy for katie couric though yeah
she really needed the money
are you ready for our fifth and final
story that's gonna lead into our tv
recap
only if it's the final story
[Applause]
chloe and tristan were seen together
after the sydney chase scandal i know
you're fatigued by this story
i know that you are but i have a new pov
i'm still fatigued i have a new pov
what's that i don't think it was true
sydney mm-hmm i think it's possible that
it wasn't true because i had i was
listening to
the podcast that she went on no jumper
that's where she
told this story and i was listening to
an episode of it because sophia
with an f was on okay and they brought
up the fact that this girl came on the
show and said this thing about tristan
and the show received the season assist
and the host yeah saying you have to
take that part out and he's like so we
did but like literally the clip is
everywhere right
but the host was like this girl he
didn't even know this girl i don't know
what she does i think she like had this
opportunity and just like said some
stuff
and when when tasked with showing proof
she
declined to show any instead saying her
lawyers would handle the situation
by the way i think that chloe and
tristan are always going to have to deal
with like
accusations both true and false and i
and i'm now starting to see this in a
different light but on the preview for
the next reunion andy says how did you
know that he wouldn't do it again like
after jordan once and she was like he
did
no it was after the um when he
cheated on her when she was pregnant
yeah that wasn't jordan that wasn't
jordan who was that that was just
someone else okay and and then when she
said he did do it again
i think that was jordan wow i told him
and i'm sure that that's the plan with
jordan i'm sure there were other
cheating things in between but but i
think since then and since like the
reformation of
tristan woods there's been nothing
tristan thompson like and he's put in
all this work and now we're seeing it
play out on the show
i'm a believer i'm i'm just starting to
see it differently
you know by the way i'm not fatigued
because like i think he keeps cheating
i'm just like done with these people
like this story is
exhausting i've given so much of my life
my
heart to this couple like we literally
did a two-hour episode on the jordan
woods red table talk like i've just
given so much of my
life and at this point like i just don't
want to keep up with the thompsons
anymore like i really don't i have
considered them
china nope i i unshined them and we're
50 50 here on the
china ing so i'm gonna keep i just want
to say like watching them on the show i
was pretty much done with them and
really fatigued but then seeing them
together on the show like
made me interested yeah i was like
i i liked how he was being so sweet but
like part of me thought it was
disingenuous like i just don't know
disingenuous
no like seeing on the show his
personality was so different from what i
expected yes
and so it piqued my interest
i'm just like exhausted like i'm so
tired i'm sick and tired of being sick
and tired
you're a little dramatic but yes i'm
nothing if not dramatic
well you know i just i want the best for
them and i and i want them to leave us
alone and i want them us to leave them
alone
i'm saying that they want the same 100
but then when people are claiming
that he cheated and the whole world
believes it because you know once you
cheat are always a cheater
and what if that wasn't true now they're
spotted back together which makes me
think like
maybe it wasn't true well this is a
great segue into the keeping up with the
kardashians finale because i did find it
really interesting how
for so long i always thought like chloe
was the toughest one and i think she was
for a while but just like years and
years
of being the tough one of putting
literally she didn't say it and andy
asked did you feel like you put the show
on her back and the answer is
unequivocally yes like all the rob and
lamar stuff and then the divorce and
then lamar again and then chloe and
tristan and then tristan and jordan
chris cheating when she was pregnant
there is no doubt that chloe has opened
up the most on this show like out of
anyone
and it's obviously taken a toll on her
because she's like not that tough girl
that she used to be anymore like it has
worn on her and it was actually really
sad
to kind of come to that conclusion like
just watching her on the show
and she's such a good sister and she's
so supportive of all of her sisters but
she also really has like
bled out most for the show and i thought
that was like one of my biggest
takeaways from the
from the reunion was that like just
justice for chloe and like all these
like scandals with her face like she's
just
she's traumatized i thought she looked
so good she looked amazing but like with
all these social media scandals like
flowy kardashian and like everyone being
like who's that migraine commercial
it's obvious that like she's just like a
victim
of like her trauma and like all these
years of just like being called the fat
sister that's not really her dad like
that has worn on her like this is what
we get and like everyone is just like
constantly piling on in on her and like
i just left the reunion with like a huge
amount of like sadness for chloe
oh interesting i didn't feel that way
necessarily i just left the reunions
just like
loving loving these gals yes even more
if that's possible
and hearing them go back to the
beginning and just like even kim talking
about like the sex tape how we wouldn't
be here without it but like if
i really do have one regret like it's
that that's out there but like also
talking about how
even though from our pov it was like kim
was the star and her sisters were just
like
along for the ride it's like her sisters
made her star too like that if it was
just kim she wouldn't be
kim kardashian yeah no she's just not as
interesting on her own and like it was
just really
cute and sweet to hear it all from their
perspective well kim is so humble like
she gives so much respect to
her family to their mom to paris like
she doesn't act like none of the [ __ ]
that ever she doesn't act like she used
to not be desperate and i think that's
why
like i love her so much like she's very
clear about her intentions from day one
yeah when she was talking about going to
the ivy to pick up a piece of bread to
get over it's like glasses here
hysterical so funny and like that's just
like the realness that you love and what
i really liked about the reunion is that
i feel like these last couple seasons of
kardashians we just watch them on their
phones and they're just like
yeah like literally and you forget that
they're all like really smart business
women and they're like
very articulate and i just feel like we
really got to see them speak in full
sentences
for such a long period of time and i was
like wow they're all really you know
introspective and smart and
and i just had forgotten that because
the show had gotten to be like literal
silence
yeah totally you know no it's a really
really good point like they were asked
questions that they had to respond to
and they just responded well and they
just like never talk on the show anymore
yeah no it's a really good point yeah
yeah yeah
um i just loved it and i loved seeing
chloe i mean seeing
kylie and i just i've said that i think
i said this like last week like i just
love chris
like just obsessed and i like that and
he asked some really good questions
just you know this whole chris jenner
works hard but the devil whatever the
devil works hard but chris jenner works
harder
and kim was like that actually really
bothers me like we're all so busy you
think my mom is out planning stories
about all of us
hurting the other ones like we are so
close we are a family and that's why
we're so successful is because we've
never stabbed each other in the back
and so chris isn't going around laying
stories about different kids to take
like that's just not what she's doing
and i don't believe that either yeah no
i'm glad that he brought that up
and it is funny like to hear their
perspective on it because it's like such
a part of the
culture now um another part that i
really
liked oh the chris humphrey stuff we
must discuss
fascinating fascinating and like i don't
know why but for me it's like still a
store subject and
you were their like big biggest champion
and they were laughing a little too hard
last night okay
oh my god 100 you know like i'm glad
that they can laugh about it but like
a little too much a little too but i
think kim really explained it very well
how like when she saw him recently like
he wouldn't even
like look her in the eye because he's so
faith-based and he only wanted to have
one marriage and i think that's like a
really good explanation for like
why he feels bad yeah and why he wanted
an annulment and by the way explaining
like that fraud piece makes so much
sense
because the fraud thing became a huge
storyline yeah that he felt he frauded
in their marriage but no you need to
prove fraud in order to get an annulment
and
i appreciated that she said if she had
been more mature she would have given
him that annulment
and i wish that maybe that that had
happened and i i do stand by and it even
last night like made me realize i don't
think kim and chris were ever going to
be like
together forever but they had absolutely
no shot when they moved into an
apartment
within a hotel in a hotel with scott and
courtney during the nba lockout and
chris wasn't working and they're
literally in two bedrooms
and his shoes are all around the room
yeah they never had a chance yeah but
they weren't gonna work out they would
have lasted more than 72 days if they
had like a real place to live and chris
was working yeah obviously so i bring
the nba lockout
up i really do and his big shoes
i just honestly why i loved that whole
segment was when i feel like we got a
lot of good insight into what actually
what happened because people are always
like
you know she did it for the ratings for
the money she's like i wouldn't have
spent our 10 million dollars from our
salary our fees and our production money
on this stupid [ __ ] wedding if it was
fake but i also
loved how she's just like and i think
this is something we can all like learn
she's so like modest and humble and
she's really
very comfortable admitting when she's
wrong she's not trying to defend her
decision she actually says like
i wish i just gave him the annulment
because then i would only be married one
time now
and it meant a lot to him and i should
have just done that for him after like
all we went through yeah so i just loved
that she was like a really like a big
woman about it you know
is there an expiration date on when you
can get an annulment
probably like imagine they do it now oh
well they're already divorced you can't
go back and undo a divorce and get an
annulment
oh okay um also my favorite part of the
reunion was such a
small little minor little detail but i
love
how andy calls chloe chloe and she goes
hey ende
like it was just so little but i love
that and i don't know why
andy calls her that but it's so funny it
because yeah she has like a symbol on
her e yeah
um sorry someone's calling me i'm so
popular
um
[Laughter]
who was it it's my um
car service i'm going to tpg's right
after oh fancy lady um but we're
he's early so it's not my problem um
what else happened that i wanted to talk
about
courtney was like a little too excited
to like
repeat what paris hilton had said about
kim
you know i mean she's like kim's like i
don't remember she said something like
mean about my butt and i called it fat
and then literally courtney's spaced out
turns back word for it oh she said it
was a pillow case filled with
bars of soap or like whatever she said a
dump truck garbage bag cottage cheese in
a trash bag thank you cottage cheese in
the trash bag which is
so mean oh i didn't think it was mean
that courtney repeated it because
honestly like i'm sitting there knowing
what it was you know
but i just think courtney got like a
little too much pleasure
oh no i think she was like she was happy
that she knew the answer
and was able to provide context i don't
know what i did also find really
interesting is every time andy asked
them like a kind of deep question
whether chloe answered it or came
answered it they both said well you know
kim and i were just talking about this
chloe and i were just having
it's obviously kim and chloe are really
close like that's what i took away from
it
yeah me too and i feel like we always
talk like that too i don't know because
sometimes when like we've
just had a conversation now i'm gonna
like say it again it's so fake i know i
just feel like i need to like
i don't know why i'm not gonna pretend
like we didn't just talk about it even
not on the show whenever i'm talking to
someone
me too jackie and i were just talking
about this or like i'm in a room with
people and i have
a conversation with someone and then the
next person i'm like oh i was just
talking about i don't know why i feel
the need to do that because you're so
authentic and i just need to like just
keep things factual yeah i'm so
authentic you're so authentic like you
can't pretend like you haven't had this
conversation before because that
wouldn't be true to you it's so true and
it's like i just need to let you know
i'm repeating everything i just said and
i just noticed that happened like a few
times in the reunion so i'm like oh they
obviously are really close and they talk
about like a lot of serious stuff
yeah when they were talking about who
kim was dating she said she wasn't
dating van jones
she said she wasn't dating maluma but
she didn't say i'm not dating anyone
she's like i'm not dating van jones
as if like there was someone she is
dating i expect that there is someone
she's dating after
years of like them not even being
married i think she's definitely in a
relationship
i'm so glad they gave us clarity on
those rumors because now we can start to
really
look at the sea look at the ships
and see what we can start building and
i'm really happy for van jones that he
used it as an opportunity
to get other girls so like every truly
everyone wins
yes um i just loved it i thought it was
so well done i thought there was no
frou-frou like usually a part one is
like a waste of time
there was not a wasted minute i could
have watched it all
night me too and they just looked
gorgeous
a lot of people are like clowning on
kendall for her outfit i think it was
very cool like if i looked like that i
would wear like a tank top too
a hundred percent like it's fine
honestly it wasn't crazy about kylie's
outfit
i think they all looked really great
chris angelic
yeah i just if i could on and i know it
sounds crazy because if i could raid any
closets
of the kardashians it would deadass be
chris's like she's just so mature and
elegant and that's who i want to be and
like i want to be
a rich 65 year old at 26 if that makes
sense
yeah i would rate her closet you would
rate who kylie's yeah i think kylie's
because it's between kylie or
kim but i think a lot of kim's clothes
are just like a little too abstract
yeah um avant-garde yeah and kylie's are
like more wearable and fun
whose closet would you rate let us know
in the comments yeah no i mean they're
all really good chloe's closet
is fun too and also more approachable
than the others yeah she wears jeans
candles but it just wouldn't fit me
but even when i'm talking no
hypothetically no sizes like of course
no sizes but like even the cut of like
kendall would wear low-rise jeans
i would not but if you ever shop like
they do kardashian closet
for um all the time i look all the time
but i'm the same sizes as
kylie and kim i'm the same shoe size
as kim not kylie she's got a bigfoot um
so it is really interesting like i look
all the time too when i
never look at clothes because it's
non-refundable and honestly like if i
ever find something in my size it's just
it's too risky i go for like jewelry
bags and shoes
always the first things to go yeah no i
i almost bought one of kylie's coats
like a few
months ago i wanted a winter coat but i
just like didn't pull the trigger i just
nothing's moved me enough to like make a
cart on the website i've never bought
anything but i peruse
constantly i like bought stuff like 10
years ago from like kim's closet yeah
um i love that they're wrapping it up on
sunday we don't have to wait a whole
other week
and i just loved it i really did
i'm looking forward to getting clarity
on scott and the younger girls because
he said something like it's not what
everybody thinks everyone thinks it's
wrong and then chris was like you tell
them scott so like clearly there's
something we don't know is amelia not
nineteen or yeah is she lying about her
age yeah
i'm curious to hear about that as well
um
it was just great i loved it and i gave
it 10 out of 10 and i can't wait to
watch part 2 10 out of 10 100
that's our show it is our show thank you
guys so much for a great week here at
the morning toast thank you for
listening
hope everyone has an amazing weekend
stay safe happy juneteenth
and we'll see you on monday thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial
morning show where we deliver the past
life stories that you need to know every
monday through friday and youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's spotify i can stitch
your public radio i have radio cat box
all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us morning toasted leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are hope you guys
have an amazing weekend we'll see you on
monday
[Music]
goodbye